now that they've seen what steel can do  it's time to test this myth will the  Rocks match the metal and break up on  impact  versus the castle in three  two one  oh that sounded like damage to me  that did some serious damage and it  shattered meaning there's nothing to  send back but even though it penetrated  one layer and damaged two bricks the  softer Sandstone ball couldn't match the  damage of the metal boss so next it's  Limestone versus Carrie's Dream Castle  it certainly was because the Limestone  was hard enough to destroy three bricks  closer to the damage the steel ball cost  and more importantly it disintegrated on  impact